that's good you need something mindless
every now and then it's mindless why are
you guys watching euphoria i can't do it
i can't do it i don't want to watch kids
on drugs [ __ ] i it's like the last
thing i want wild well the lady loves it
so i'm watching it you know next to her
reading a book or on my phone and i'm
just like
it's good it's good i mean it's like
heavy [ __ ] every episode is like a
what's that movie
with the the drug use with jared leto
oh um
requiem
yeah the crying the drugs the [ __ ]
the trans but it's good it's all it's
good it's good people love it
mind-boggling it's like the biggest hbo
show in forever really after you finish
an episode you have to you have to take
a breather i don't know i need this
before i'm on the road give me reacher
yeah
you might like with the the teenage
people but i think the young dano's in
it but uh
i need to reach around ah richer
all right it's so dumb how we doing are
we okay yeah we're good we got a couple
boxes on the table oh let's go good call
peters what do we got
yeah what do you got there oh this is i
mean like you think i can read this
[ __ ] handwriting jesus christ let's
give me that like oh geez let's let me
see i can put this together it's a
serial killer
ironically you two are some of the best
joke writers in comedy and so i wanted
to gift a recommendation that's a little
symbolic
enclosed are three fountain pens called
scribe swords
one for each of you and the offer for
joe list if he wants it by the way we
might be drunk
and tuesdays when are they going to
collab writing jokes is a craft so why
not treat the craft with the respect it
deserves fountain pens are so much more
enjoyable to work with than ball points
and cuz and causes significantly less
fatigue over time
this is my wreck to everyone out there
invest in a high quality single purpose
items [ __ ] all that digital [ __ ] that's
more of a distraction than a productive
tool right quality jokes with quality
tools and get yourself a fountain pen
you doi we're quality tools right here
yeah
uh yeah i'll give it a shot i've never
done it i'm not carrying this whole case
around though today no you don't want to
be that guy
but yeah hey thanks dude
oh
thank you boss
look at that wow it's like a pool cue
jesus thanks for choosing scribe sword